现在是跟我男朋友差不多，
就最近打算住在一起嘛，
完了他又把他的那个工资全转给我了，
那他的那个工资就攒了个8000多块钱嘛，
但是付房租的话，
我付了1万多，
就相当于我自己也输了很多，
然后我又担心他这个事情，
就是他这个工资转给我之后，
万一以后要是分手的话，
他就把他要回去，
那我又不是很那什么嘛，
就是怎样才能堡护自己一点呢？
确实啊，
就是从法律上来说，
他现在转给你的钱，
他有证据去证明，
将来万一有一天要分手了，
他可以说我这个是以结婚为目的的这样一个赠与，
呃，
就算是彩礼，
然后呢，
你还得就是零存整取的退给人家，
这个确实在法律上是成立的，
但你这头如果能够证明我们俩是共同生活的，
我们俩共同租这个房子的，
然后房租是我交的，
也能够起到一定的抵扣的作用，
但问题的关键就在于，
你不光是要出房租，
你可能生活当中你还得买菜，
呃，
出去吃饭，
去逛电影院，
出去玩儿，
各种消费，
因为他把所有工资都转给你了，
肯定是你来出这个钱交费，
对不对？
嗯，
是的，
水电费，
所有买菜钱，
然后包括他说请朋友吃饭什么的，
都是我自己来付，
你要之前他工资虽然给我了，
但是其实一个人家都在。
他花对到最后你根本没有办法证明，
我觉得啊，
这个事情啊，
你干脆你给他转2000让他交房租得了，
给他转2000让他交房租是吧，
相当于你俩合租了啊，
啊上次的房租就是他把我钱转我这儿之后，
然后我全部付给那个房东去，
但是当时我转账的时候有备注，
呃，
到几月几号的那个房租我是有备注的，
因为到最后真的是要打官司的话，
你第一步你得证明你跟他同居麻烦的，
对于我们女孩子是吧，
我还证明我跟一个男的同居，
还要找出那些聊天记录，
我俩什么挺麻烦的，
你还不如像龙慧姐刚刚说的那个方法，
就是你给他转2000，
他交房租，
那这样子不是你们年轻人生活怎么能这么干呢？
总共工资8000，
房租搞1万多，
年轻人能不能学着攒点钱，
那个房租的话是房租呢，
是一个月是1500，
那我们是付了半年嘛，
就七七八八的，
连押金年各种物业费加起来的话，
这一次是不是付没了1万多，
我还以为说一个月1万多，
我那之后他的工资转我，
我还是照样收的，
然后付房租的话就还给他，
让他去付取也行啊，
就比如说平时我买菜呀，
或者说出去吃饭呀，
什么，
我跟他拍照发朋友圈，
那个管用吗？
然后再留那个发票票据什么的那种姑娘不要给自己添那么多。
麻烦你想啊，
你以后真的要分手的时候，
你一笔一笔去算这个账，
你头不头疼很烦呀，
但是吧，
就是之前的时候他没有把钱给我嘛，
然后差不多就在我家做了3个月吧，
就是房租水电都是我出的，
然后之前家里面买的什么所有东西全让我出的，
然后就因为这个吵了一架嘛，
所以他才把给我们全转给我，
让我来管他把工资全转给你，
是不是该交了什么钱你再转给他，
交房租了你再转给他，
该交水电了你再转给他，
该吃饭了你再转给他，
这样都有证据啊，
来来往往的都有证据也是，
然后我我之前就留了一个失业，
我跟他说让他转我支付宝，
然后微信要付钱的话，
付什么我就转到支付宝上，
让他提前去微信付去，
我信这么弄会有什么区别呢？
他都有记录，
对支付宝的话在我这就我付嘛，
微信的话就他付，
就相当于是委婉的把钱转给他，
没有跟他扯这些东西嘛，
就委婉的转给他，
但是我的意思就是这个留个证据，
要不然全是我付的话，
可能所有的费用都是我在消费了，
就是说你不想是微信上来来往往的这么看着不好看，
然后他给你转完了之后，
你再微信转给他，
是这样不支付宝跟微信就分开的，
他的东西一般都是支付宝转给我，
然后如果说要付什么的话，
我就那个微信转给他啊，
也行也行啊，
我很烦，
我也不想。
这么累，
如果说他不给我那个工资吧，
就所有的东西都是我在付，
那我代付的话，
说实话我一个人承担两个人的开销，
我还是觉得有点压力的，
因为我自己也要攒点钱的嘛，
是的啊，
他养成了这个习惯，
什么钱都要你来付的话，
确实他存在这种法律风险，
就是人家临存整取，
你这你存了8万块钱，
然后分手的时候问你要8万，
然后你这头还证明不了你钱花到哪里去了，
你还证明不了是你两个人花了呢，
证明不了是属于共同生活的，
那就麻烦了啊呀，
所以我就是担心这个，
万一要是分手的话，
他找我要这个钱，
然后，
但是钱呢，
都花我俩身上去了，
我又怎么还他呢？
嗯，
那你就让他付款呗，
让他付房租呗，
让他付饭钱呗，
让他付呗，
每次对吧，
要出门之前你先给他转500，
你俩一起再出门了，
这样子还可以好吧，
还有一个事就是那个是关于我家里面的事情，
就是之前其实我有联系过你的，
然后我爸妈妈就是离婚的，
然后我爸说找了个后嘛，
但是我爸最近老是跟我要钱的，
就三天两头的跟我哭穷，
他可能知道我自己有一点钱吧，
他就跟我哭穷，
就跟我要钱，
你爸多大年纪啊，
我爸50多了吧，
他自己没工作吗？
他有的，
他自己做了点小生意的，
就属于做那种小工程嘛，
就是。
不知道怎么回事儿，
反正就经常就跟我哭穷嘛，
我觉得可能是跟我后妈有关系，
我后妈老瞅着他来跟我要钱嘛，
然后他要回老家的时候，
回老家去有事嘛，
他连那个油钱什么的都给我算的清清楚楚的，
然后我当时给他转2000块钱，
我我一个星期呢，
一个星期都没有又跟我要钱了，
我说我没钱，
我在吃泡面，
然后一看见又跟我哭穷，
又说没钱了，
我都不知道要怎么弄了，
你不会吗？
你不会哭穷吗？
就我感觉，
哎，
他就那种，
他就一边就是想着说啊，
我是他女儿什么的吧，
一边的话又听我后妈的话，
又一直跟我要钱，
我就想着他那个一直跟我要钱，
他也不是说真的没钱，
他做那个工程嘛，
就还是有点钱的，
就可能说是他投入之后会投一些钱进去嘛，
但他自己肯定是有钱的呀，
要不然家里面也不会买那么多房子的车什么乱七八糟的，
我怀疑就是我后妈瞅着他来跟我要钱，
第一自己要学会哭穷，
第二要学会拒绝，
你得管你爸借钱，
你说爸我房租得到了，
我现在没钱了，
能借我点房租吗？
可以可以，
还有关于我这个情况的话，
就是万一要是我跟我现在这个男朋友结婚的话，
然后我怀疑我这个男朋友就是他，
万一到时候谈到什么彩礼什么的，
他会不会说钱都在我这儿，
我不可能。
说花我自己的钱再娶我自己吧，
那是非常有可能，
人家这么说的，
你自己先想好这个可么办呢？
有没有几个解决方法，
如果他原生家庭也给不到他支撑，
然后人家挣的工资都交给你了，
你问人家要彩礼，
他上哪儿给你找彩礼去，
怎么办呢？
怎么办？
龙飞姐给啊，
龙飞得给你块钱啊，
我就说有没有什么解决方法，
你的方法就是高嘛，
降低你的预期是吧，
你自己要是很能挣钱，
能养得活他，
你就别把自己当成是嫁人的，
我就是养个帅哥，
嗯，
给我提供情绪价值对吧，
陪我吃喝玩乐，
你自己很有钱，
那就可以，
如果你自己也没钱，
自己也没有这个能力，
你还是找个能给得起彩礼的吧，
你别想太多啊，
高高兴兴的过开开心的活每一天，
那现在对你好都是真心的，
感受这份真心就够了，
真到有一天分手了，
分手了就分手了呗。
杨幂说那句话啊，
都那样都那样，
但现在你体会的真心是真实的，
你能感受到的那种是真实的就可以了。
嗯，
是的，
现在感觉还行吧，
就之前有吵过架，
不是分手，
那时候分手，
然后后面他又会跟我讲那些道理，
然后又来解决问题之类的，
我觉得还行吧，
自己想明白了，
想通透了就没问题。
嗯，
拜拜，
我最近这段时间不是又看到什么明星这又分手了，
那又分手了嘛，
而我现在这种心态啊，
就有点老太太心态，
不管跟谁在一起，
将来到底有50%的概率要分手，
那我们需要做的是什么呢？
天呐啊，
在一起就好好在一起，
最起码我们现在此时此刻，
我们对彼此是付出了真心实意的，
我们是付出了我们真感情的，
就很好了。
真到有一天分手了是吧，
我也不占你经济上的便宜，
你也别占我经济上的便宜，
接纳分手这个事情，
但我此时此刻我享受每天是吧，
我们彼此付出了真心的，
我真的关心你，
你也真的在乎我，
就享受这个时这个这个阶段就可以了，
老想着以后要分手，
所以我今天就不付出真心了，
这个日子也不是这么回事儿，
我不知道大家有没有跟我有同感的，
你老想着将来有50%的概率要分手，
你今天就不付出真心了，
那你永远得不到真心，
因为真心从来都是相对应的，
你对人家真不真心，
人家能感受得到的，
你是不是骑驴找马，
人家也能感受得到的。